[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
expressvpn what is VPN virtual private
network it's an app that you run on your
computer or your mobile device it
secures your internet connection hides
your public IP address and lets you
bypass regional restrictions on content
and I actually asked my followers on
Twitter 1.5 or 1.6 million of you for
VPN recommendations your favorites many
wrote back that expressvpn was their
favorite including a number of people
who've been on this podcast so I gave it
a shot I've been using it for a few
weeks now and it is ridiculously fast to
the extent that I thought I didn't have
it on to give you an idea expressvpn has
consistently rated the fastest VPN
service on the market it's incredibly
easy to use
and it's one two three just download the
app tap one button and you're connected
to a secure VPN server and I recommend
checking out the website just to see the
signup flow they make it really smooth
very easy to sign up and if you're an
entrepreneur or do any web-based
front-end development or design rather
it's worth checking out for that alone
so expressvpn what are we talking about
here Express VPN is great for when you
need to get work done while you're on
some sketchy Wi-Fi network for instance
and I've had a number of hacker friends
of mine show me how easy it is to snoop
on public Wi-Fi just by downloading
simple apps you do not need a computer
science background to do that which
scares the hell out of me so if you
don't want to be a victim of that you
can use Express VPN or if you're
traveling I need to access something
that's only available in another country
well lickety-split expressvpn has you
covered
Express VPN is useful not only for
entrepreneurs and remote workers and
travelers like yours truly but really
for anyone who wants protection from
being snooped on or
their personal data stone so I use it
constantly when I'm in airports coffee
shops and so on any public Wi-Fi really
you just use the Internet like you
normally would but with expressvpn
encrypting all of your network traffic
to safeguard your data so check it out
visit my special link at expressvpn comm
slash to him and you'll get an extra
three months of expressvpn protection
for free
that's expressvpn dot-com slash Tim to
claim your special deal visit expressvpn
comm slash Tim this episode is brought
to you by ship station if you've ever
sold anything online or if you sell
anything online then you know what a
pain in the ass the shipping process is
it's time-consuming it's expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in previous life
I shipped tens of thousands of units
overseas domestically overnight ground
every possible carrier it drove me
bonkers ship station was created to make
your life easier I wish I had had it
when I was in the biz so to speak it has
the most five-star reviews of any
shipping software four point nine out of
five for Magento users four point eight
out of five for Shopify users four point
five out of five for big commerce users
it goes on and on whether you're selling
on eBay Amazon Shopify or more than 100
other popular selling channels
shipstation lets you access all of your
orders from one simple dashboard
shipstation works with all of the major
shipping carriers locally and globally
including FedEx UPS and the major local
couriers like USPS ship station will
recommend the best carrier for your
needs so that you know that you're
always getting the best deal they even
offer discounts on shipping costs that
are available to say you as a one-person
shop that would normally be thought of
as reserved for large fortune 500
companies so there are a lot of benefits
no other shipping platform makes
shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss you
listeners get to try ship station free
for 60 days when you use
code Tim it's risk-free you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info
just visit ship station com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Tim T IM that ship station
comm enter promo code Tim check it out
ship station comm promo code Tim hello
boys and girls ladies and germs this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job every episode to deconstruct
world class performers of all different
types to tease out the principles habits
thinking influences and so on that help
them to do what they do and my guest
today does not grant many interviews and
he came to me through avenues that I
would not have expected his name is
Charles Koch and I had several of my
close friends very very accomplished in
business all very socially liberal who
had become friends with Charles and
suggested that I have him on the podcast
and will talk more about that I'm sure
but let's get into the bio and this
episode no doubt will excite the
internet because there is a case of
insanity going around and I would
encourage you to listen and to focus on
what I hope to transmit which is the
importance of attacking the problems not
the people we'll come back to that let's
get to the bio Charles Koch received a
bachelor's degree in general engineering
and two master's degrees in nuclear and
chemical engineering from the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
MIT he is chairman of the board and CEO
of Koch Industries Inc a position he has
held since 1967 he was renowned for
growing koch industries from a company
worth 21 million in the early 1960s to
one with revenues estimated as high as
110 billion that's annually by forbes
it's one of the largest privately held
companies in the world and by revenue
it's larger than both Boeing and Disney
let that sink in he has transformed the
business into a diverse group of
companies that employ nearly a hundred
and thirty thousand people making
everything Dixie Cups to come
in your cellphone for 50 years Charles
has supported academic and public policy
research with a special focus on
developing voluntary market-based
solutions to social problems this
interest led him to found or helped
build a number of organizations
including the Institute for Humane
studies the Cato Institute the Mercatus
Center at George Mason University and
the Bill of Rights Institute
Charles credits the success of Koch
Industries to applying proven principles
of social and scientific progress which
led to the development and
implementation of his market-based
Management mbm business philosophy he
describes mbm and its applications in
two of his books the science of success
and good profit Charles is now using
those principles in philanthropy as the
founder of stand together to tackle our
country's biggest challenges stand
together is partnering with thousands of
social entrepreneurs to help them
improve their effectiveness and scale
attack like poverty improving K through
12 education bringing justice to our
criminal justice system and more I have
more to say so don't fast forward but
you can find out more about both Koch
Industries and stand together at Koch in
calm K och IND calm stand together org
which I highly encourage you to check
out if you are a social entrepreneur or
know social entrepreneurs in need of
support and capital on Twitter at Koch
Industries and at stand underscore
together it takes us a little while to
get warmed up as it often does in these
podcast interviews so give it you know
5-10 minutes to get into flow but we
talked about a lot we talked about books
that have had the greatest influence on
his thinking and actions thinkers we
talked about for instance the
differences in acquisition strategy
between Koch Industries and Berkshire
Hathaway we really go all over the place
and I also asked him some of the
questions that were submitted by people
following me on social media and there
are some real haymakers that I do read
towards the latter portions of this
conversation so I do not simply serve up
softballs that's not the intention and
that's certainly not the way that I run
this podcast in general so
this episode why would I do this why
would I deliberately polarize my
audience because of identity politics
and people applying labels to themselves
it caused so many problems and I'm not
referring to Charles I'm referring to a
lot of people among my listeners no
doubt it's because I believe much like
Paul Graham does one of the cofounders
of Y Combinator that the more labels you
apply to yourself the stupider you
become and the more prone you are to
groupthink and it's very very dangerous
and in this episode my role I view is
not to get you to like or dislike
Charles but to pay attention to his
thinking which I do think is remarkable
and I will just mention a few things to
calm down many of my friends out there
who are predominantly liberal I did live
in the Bay Area for 20 years after all
to try to encourage them further to
listen to this whole thing number one I
would say that Charles has been very
active in collaborating with previous
adversaries on criminal justice reform
including CNN commentator Van Jones
they shared or found they shared common
principles when it came to reforming
this country's criminal justice system
and that is the topic that actually was
brought up by a lot of my friends who
encouraged me to do this podcast and in
partnership with van Charles helped to
build a nonpartisan policy coalition
that passed historic criminal justice
reform last year on foreign policy
despite disagreements with George Soros
on many other policy issues as you can
imagine Charles discovered that he had
common ground with him when it came to
foreign policy so they partnered with
George's Open Society Foundations to
launch the Quincy Institute for
Responsible statecraft which is a new
think-tank to promote ideas that move
the u.s. foreign policy away from Warren
towards vigorous diplomacy in the
pursuit of international peace and it
goes on and on in the sense that despite
and I'm quoting the Guardian here does
being a conservative powerhouse that has
at times outspent the Republican
National Committee the Koch Network is
increasingly showing willingness to work
with Democrats and investing in
nonprofit groups to promote quote free
and open societies end quote and then
jumping forward in that piece long seen
as GOP kingmakers David and Charles Koch
have made waves by lambasted Trump and
his administration they refused to back
Trump in 2016
vowed to hold him accountable to
conservative priorities like free trade
free markets and small government and
have been outspoken against the White
House on immigration and infrastructure
spending what I found is that the people
who love Charles Koch miss a lot the
ones who have the most intense views
about Charles and Koch Industries
likewise the people who hate Charles or
Koch Industries miss a lot and my hope
is that I'm able to add some nuance and
texture to this person who is often
evaluated based on headlines and also
again to encourage everybody listening
much like I feel Charles does very
effectively to attack the problems and
not the people I think that's the only
path forward really is to instead of
asking how to most effectively fight
against someone to first ask yourself
what you might have in common in terms
of priorities so that you can align in
some fashion without that we're all
doomed I think in short or long order
either way that's a long intro but I'm
happy to provide this and I'm sure that
the feedback will be strong in all sorts
of directions without further ado please
enjoy my wide-ranging conversation with
Charles Koch
Charles welcome to the show thanks Tim
thanks for having me oh I appreciate you
taking the time and I've had a number of
my friends over the last it's a year
year and a half who have have wanted me
to interview you and who are fans of a
lot of what you've done the the the main
subject that has come up a lot is
criminal justice reform which I'm sure
we will get to and there's a lot to
cover I thought we would start with
dandelions can you tell me about your
history with digging dandelions well I
was I really consider myself blessed
because I had the best of all possible
worlds looking back it didn't seem that
way at the time but we were wealthy and
my father he called himself a half-baked
chemist and he loved doing experiments
so we lived on a an experimental farm it
wasn't a commercial farm but it was a
farm where my father could experiment
with various things so we had we had
cows horses dogs chickens and raised
crops and and my father announced at an
early age he said I don't want any my
sons to grow up to be country club bums
and I was a metal child on a brother
who's two years older and two younger
brothers who were twins were four and a
half years younger than I was and so my
father started this on my older brother
and he was more of an artistic bent so
the this manual labor that involved
helping out on this experimental farm
didn't work as well for him and so I
bore the brunt of it and you may ask why
why did I bear well that was one reason
and as he put it I asked him years later
I said pop why were you so much tougher
on me than my younger brothers and he
said son you plum wore me out and so
high I earned the right to be in more
trouble get knocked around more and do
more work so I started he started me out
in all my spare time working and the
first was digging dandelions the reason
I say digging you can't just cut them
off or pull them you've got to get all
the roots out or they just come back so
that was my job and then I graduated in
two and shoveling out stalls feeding the
animals milking cows digging postholes
fixing fence and all that stuff and then
as I got older I got jobs in other
places so it was it was quite an
opportunity to learn the value of work
and learn that I better develop some
skills that other people will value or I
could end up doing this the rest of my
life which I didn't look forward to he
used to say that he said I was a good
kid in many ways as long as the work
didn't come too close and so I had I had
what's the economists call a high time
preference that is I was into instant
gratification how could I minimize the
work how could I do something that's
fine so that was my whole orientation
and and then I was blessed that I
thought the only thing I was good at was
getting in trouble and I was I was
pretty expert at that and I found in the
third grade that I had a gift in in math
and I later learned when I studied study
psychology I read a Howard Gardner and
his multiple intelligence theories and
boy did that fit me because the only
thing I was good at was what he called
logical mathematical intelligence and so
I had a gift for math and abstract
concepts so basically
my whole life has been defined
opportunities that that used that that I
could create value with that and then to
partner with people who were good at all
the other things that needed to be done
that I wasn't good at and or dreamed
possible
is because I've done that whenever I've
tried to do things by myself or without
that kind of of support I've basically
failed I want to ask a bit more about
your dad
specifically about a believe you still
have it I would imagine so a framed
letter that you found in your father's
safe-deposit box after his death can you
talk about the letter that is on your
wall and why it's important to you
yeah he wrote that in you know I take
January of of 1936 and I was let's say I
was born in November so I was let's say
three months old and so he wrote it to
my older brother and me and in there he
talked about adversity provides the
greatest lessons and is certainly the
greatest character builder and then his
hope for us and whatever he had given us
that we used it we didn't misuse that or
wasted but used it so we could
experience the glorious feeling of
accomplishment and so that's everything
he did whether I liked it at the time
was toward that end and so he and I
think this is so important for anyone
who's a parent and certainly we've tried
to do that is you don't lecture your
kids on anything that you don't live up
to and he exemplified integrity humility
treating others with respect and and as
he used to preach to me son learn
everything you can you never know when
it will come in handy and so those who
are all
lessons and and there was no hypocrisy
in there I mean that's the way he lived
when you ended up after your education
so after MIT you were talked back to
Wichita and my understanding is that he
had an equipment company that wasn't
doing well and effectively said you can
run it any way you want the one thing
you would need approval for is selling
it was that the time that your dad
fascinates me because I think you might
have been correct me again if I'm wrong
but about 26 I have a piece of advice
that that he gave you and it's I hope
your first deal is a loser
otherwise you'll think you're a lot
smarter than you are so it really seems
that your dad was focused on preserving
your sort of initiative and drive so
that the the the wealth wouldn't become
a curse or there are other things that
he did when you first joined the
business to facilitate that could be
before or after but I'm wondering what
that initial experience was like yeah we
had my father the the way he got me to
come back he had been after me I was
working for a consulting firm in in
Boston and learning a lot and I got to
work in all different phases this wasn't
just a management consulting I started
in product development and then I did
process development and then I worked in
an innovation group and I kept
maneuvering so I got to try different
things I was looking for something that
I could use what a few gifts I had and
in a way that would be productive in
that and that I'd be passionate about
and and by the way I had the reason I
was able to get into MIT and as I
started my my time preference change
rather than being instant gratification
I I started
I got a much lower time preference and
that is I became focused on the long
term on on studying and developing these
aptitudes and looking for a calling that
I could use to create value for others
and that would make me successful and
and that I would be fulfilled by so I
would be passionate about it and and
work so I through all this that I worked
in in multiple departments that are
thirty little and and I just
Charles Manson I apologize that could be
talked about I just want to pause on the
switch that you made so how did you
because a lot of people never make the
switch from instant gratification to
this longer term focus what catalyzed
that for you well I think it's it's and
I said this my father always had me
doing dirty jobs and I was minimizing
the my work effort I put into it and at
some point I figure out this is a dead
end what am i doing and and it been
maybe his lessons in his example seeped
in and so I started started reading
probably as a junior in high school
started reading start with novels and
then at MIT I I got three degrees in
engineering there but I was a lousy
engineer but I was good at the concepts
behind engineering but not on how to
apply anything so I maximized the taking
the courses in theory and so I took
mathematics for nuclear engineers all
these abstractions because that's what I
was good at and so not that I've used a
lot of that but it really helped develop
my aptitudes and so then as I got to
work some in business and business
consulting I found while this came
naturally because what I was good at in
were things like vision philosophy
strategy logically analyzing problems
and looking at the other side what could
go wrong rather than just go with
whatever ideas we had but to really
experiment test them applied the
scientific method to them which I part
of which I learned at MIT part of which
I learned afterwards and I'd love to you
and we can we can certainly bounce
around I mean that's sort of the nature
of a lot of these conversations but if
we could talk about books because it it
certainly seems like books have had a
large influence in your life and in your
book good profit you wrote I am a
bonafide book person my home contains
more books than I'll ever have time to
count in the walls of my Wichita office
are lined with them - what are what are
some of the books that have had the
largest impact on your thinking and -
I'd love for you to in addition to
anything else you might mention I'd love
for you to describe what impact - books
had that came up repeatedly my reading
FA Harper's why wages rise and I'm
probably gonna pronounce this name so
you can correct me but Ludwig von Mises
or Ludwig von Mises I'm not sure no reg
von Mises there we go yeah the human
action well I yeah I can talk about
those but the two the two authors that
have had the biggest influence on me are
our Abraham Maslow and Frederick Hayek
and and a lot of what we do is based on
Maslow's ideas of posi was one of the
early positive psychologists rather than
most of them in history Freud and others
had worked on the psychiatry of illness
and he took the other side he said what
can enable somebody to have a fulfilling
rewarding life and what he said
is what you can be you must be if you
are determined to live your life with a
lot developing your potential you may be
successful in other ways but you will be
deeply unhappy for the rest of your life
he said a bird has wings a bird has has
to fly what you can be you must be and
so that's and then he called that that
state of where you are fulfilling your
nature self-actualization that what you
can be you've you're becoming not that
any of us are every perfect in that
because it's a continual learning
experience and which requires ongoing
effort so that's what we've we try to
apply here at Koch Industries and that's
what we're applying in our in our
philanthropic efforts to enable
everybody to have the opportunity to
realize their potential and then what I
exit of all the insights that that he's
provided one that's I quote in the in my
book good profit that what he called
perhaps the greatest discovery in
history of mankind is that people can
live and work together in in peace and
to their mutual advantage under
generalized rules of just conduct that
is with generalized rules that enable
people to succeed by assisting others
rather than detailed rules that cause
conflicts and and people trying to
undermine each other makes all the
difference and that was from his study
of history well history philosophy
economics and so on so you put those two
together and it forms the core of my
philosophy and what's enabled me to
accomplish more than I ever was really
capable of doing you you and you and I
in in previous chats
have had Karl Popper pop up in
conversation a number of times do you
find yourself applying scientific
principles or engineering principles
that you used in your education to
business or how does Karl how does Karl
Popper fit into your thinking about
business well life no no that's the
great question the at MIT I became
fascinated with science and the
scientific method and then after I moved
back to Wichita I started studying one
of the early things I studied was the
the philosophy of science and the
scientific method and in particularly
and as one one particular essay of karl
popper's called Sciences falsification
in which he says that the true
scientific method is develop a testable
proposition now to prop proposition that
that is untestable but one that's
testable and then your obligation is to
not to go find evidence that will
support it but go out and seek
criticisms of it find what's wrong with
it and that's what we do on on
everything like we have a project or an
acquisition okay the first thing to do
is find what could go wrong and any idea
I have I let's say I have an idea for a
new strategy or a new business and so
the first thing I do is think through
okay what what are the key drivers of
success here what needs to happen and
let's say there are five different main
drivers then I go find the people who
can best show what's wrong or what could
go wrong in each of those drivers and we
get together and I go through my idea
and and each one is expected to come up
with ways that could go wrong and every
time we go through that we come up with
a better answer then I
developed and so that's critical the
other philosophers sites that I've
particularly drawn on is Palani who
wrote whose essay well a couple of
things his essay on republic of science
where the reason a scientific community
has been so productive and innovative is
that no one's in charge it's by
consensus debate and knowledge sharing
and the innovations come about by taking
different ideas and combining them in
new and novel ways and so that's what
that's another thing that we approach
that we use in management every every
one of our businesses we look at as a
laboratory for for innovation and
finding new and better ways to to do
things and new and better opportunities
Charles could you could you speak to
perhaps an example of how you have
applied the Republic of science or the
concepts therein and for people who want
to look them up first name Michael I
believe Palani will put this in the show
notes as well for folks but in terms of
information exchange recombining in
novel ways could you give a an exam a
concrete example of how that has been
applied right well the first thing we do
is is we emphasize knowledge sharing
many companies particularly large
companies operate in silos and and you
have an incentive where gosh you you
know you have an idea or you learn
something and you don't want to share it
because you may not get credit for it we
consider that the kiss of death so so we
expect everybody to share and we build
mechanisms and incentives in the company
to to encourage this internal knowledge
sharing and then we expect every every
discipline and there
business to build knowledge networks
around the world and it may not be
largely isn't something that's in in
your field or just with the competitors
but something that's going on elsewhere
and so we do that I mean for example on
on how to keep compressors from breaking
down and shutting down your whole
operation
so we one group are we built a group to
do data analytics to to take
measurements and determine what it was
near breaking down so we could repair it
before it shut the whole plant down and
then everybody and shared this knowledge
and learn from each other and this this
is our whole philosophy of mutual
benefit that is the way to get knowledge
sharing is show when you help somebody
else if the right person or group then
they will reciprocate and so we have
this culture now of knowledge sharing
what we call a republic create the
republic of science and that's that's
true for everything for not just
compressors but everything and then we
have innovation conferences that get
draw from different disciplines and
different of our businesses they get
together and throw out ideas they have
and then they then they get to know each
other so they don't just share when we
set up a structure to do it but would
they have what we call a spontaneous
order where people just naturally know
gosh I'm working on this problem who
might help me in the company and then
who can help me elsewhere in the world
who's working on something similar I
mean it's like what Newton said if I see
four others because I'm standing on the
shoulders of giants and but they don't
need to be giants anybody who who's
working on a similar problem may have an
idea that can help you
and collectively we're all smarter than
we are any of us are individually and
you know to that point I'd say that it's
it seems like you need to create systems
and incentives to reward the right type
of sharing and in I keep mentioning good
profit you've written other books but a
good profit
I've found very interesting for a number
of different reasons I mean you have
it's certainly completely politically
economic I mean you have John Mackey
co-founder of Whole Foods
who's praised it you've got General
Richard B Meyers former chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and others who've
talked about it and it's it strikes me
that sort of clarity of thought and
systems are a recurring theme so I'd
like to talk about a few things that
makes what you guys do different perhaps
from from others and one that one that
stuck out to me and we don't have to
spend a lot of time on this but was this
is on coke after Fred in Chapter two
the it was all the difference between
acquisition strategies of a coke and
Berkshire Hathaway and I believe I'm
getting this right but it says Berkshire
Hathaway buys companies when their
competitive position is attractive and
if their management is good he assures
them that he won't intervene except to
decide how to invest the cash flow then
he largely leaves them alone to operate
as they had before the acquisition coke
strategy has been to make acquisitions
when we can create additional value by
applying our capabilities I was
wondering if there any other differences
or contrasts between Berkshire Hathaway
or other companies that people might
compare co2 that that that come to mind
are there any any other differences that
really stand out to you that we haven't
talked about but I like our management
approach is based on on understanding
the principles of scientific and social
progress and and we've codified and
systematized those in in the in the
market based management in five
dimension
and then which I didn't describe in good
profit because I hadn't clearly thought
through how we applied that that enabled
us to do all the things we did that is
to in in 1961 when when I joined the
company we had two businesses the
largest one was a crude oil gathering
system in southern Oklahoma and the
other was a smaller company that that I
my father let me run initially that made
in internals for distillation columns
that was it was struggling at the time
and and since then we've increased the
value of the company 7,000 fold and
entered all these different businesses
we now have 12 business groups such as
Georgia Pacific DuPont sold nylon
business and and so forth then and well
I won't go through them all but but okay
the way we've done that is is by
creating what I now call virtuous cycles
of mutual benefit and that may be
highfalutin expression but it's it
accurately describes what we did so the
starting point is to understand what
capabilities you have that others will
value that you can use to create value
for others and and and then to find the
the opportunities for those capabilities
that will create the most value for
others and particularly others who will
reward you for that value so so our idea
that the ideal for business is to
maximize value create for others and
your profit would come solely as
compensation for that value you're
creating for others and then to
continually improve and and add to those
capabilities which and
then look for based on that what what
other opportunities are there for which
you can create superior value so so
there are two components then one is to
become preferred partner for all your
key constituencies that starts with
customers but it's includes employees
suppliers communities and society as a
whole and then the second piece is to
continually transform yourself like our
philosophy is if we in a business or you
as an individual working in an area if
you're the best in the world it's not
good enough and particularly today with
the rapid improvements in technologies
within a year or two you're going to be
obsolete if you just rest on your
laurels so you've got to be constantly
thinking on how do i improve how do i do
things differently what are the new
opportunities I mean if we had just
stayed with the crude oil gathering and
making those tower internals I mean we'd
be out of business now but it's by
applying that applying these principles
of human flourishing and to create these
beneficial cycles focusing on how do I
create value for all my constituencies
particularly those who rode is for the
value we create for them is what has
enabled us to do what we've done and is
that in essence the definition of good
profit for which the book is titled any
profit that is creating value for
customers society partners driven by
sort of voluntary a voluntary mutual
beneficial relationship it seems to map
I'd love for you if you can maybe to
confirm or clarify that and then could
you give a could you give some examples
of
what what bad profit is what are
examples of bad profit and why our job
is to produce products and services that
our customers will value more than their
best alternatives and in doing so to
constantly reduce and become more
efficient in the resources we consume in
doing that which okay how does that
benefit society it frees these resources
then to satisfy other needs so that's
what good profit is bad profit is is all
the ways they profit that that is
antithetical to to that approach that is
trying to cheat your customers
misrepresenting what you're doing and
rigging the system getting corporate
welfare protectionism of all different
kinds including protection from foreign
competition but also domestic
competition and a great example of this
is is occupational licensure in which
which they're like a third of all I
think a third of all occupations today
required some kind of government
approval whether that's it depends on
the state or locale but there are
hundreds of these which are mainly keep
people who start with nothing from being
able to do anything because some of them
require a couple years of going to
school and in paying a substantial fee
that they can't afford so it just it
keeps poor people poor rather than
enabling them to realize their potential
by developing their skills that other
people will value and this is things
like hair braiding hairdressing
manicurist yoga instructors
funeral parlors interior decorators you
name it not things that will blow people
up or anything that you think guys the
government needs to approve that so it's
it's all just cronyism protectionism and
corporate welfare you've you know one
thing that I found engaging about a good
profit and a lot of your writing is that
you're very you're very specific and
also very transparent in a lot of
respects the there are a number of other
things that fall in the book and and
please feel free to correct if I'm
getting this wrong under the category
bad profit got mandates subsidies tax
incentives import tariffs restrictions
on exports anti-competitive regulations
bailouts and I'm looking at a workbook
this is this is uh this is a way to
engage with the material a good profit
workbook for people who want to really
understand the material and one of the
questions that they pose is do coke
companies participate in bad profit if
so why how would you answer that
well you can't avoid it I mean if we for
example take steel tariffs we oppose
those even though we have 40 percent
interest in the newest steel mill in the
country in Arkansas mafic Forbes just
wrote an article about it in the last
issue big river steel and so it makes us
money but but we oppose it I mean we
play by the rules we're going to play by
the rules we're going to be other laws
and and but we're going to oppose all
the ones that that undermine the the
ideal role for business and society and
and why what are you just running a
charity no but well we we take the
long-term view and toe to rig the system
to make a quick buck
and makes people's lives worse then what
are you doing why does society need
business that's making people's lives
works
if-if-if business and individuals are
getting wealthy the only way society is
going to permit that long term is if
they're contributing to helping people
improve their lives not making it worse
so this is a problem with business today
we have business people have a bad
wealthy people have a bad reputation
because there's so much of this cronyism
and protectionism going on like we
oppose the the Board of Adjustment tax
like 20% tax on oil imports even though
we determined it in the most liked of
case that would make us over a billion
dollars a year by increasing the cost of
living to Walmart and Costco buyers and
and we helped get that defeated because
as I as I told the the leaders in
Republic and I said how does this make
sense are you gonna promote this we're
for this because it's going to make coke
industries a lot of money and probably
big exporters like Boeing and General
Electric will probably never pay tax
again and it will increase the cost of
living for the great majority of people
in this country particularly those who
are least well-off and of course they
had they had their reasons but it didn't
make sense and and so we and others got
it defeated but the sad thing as you
could to tell what the great majority of
companies what whether they were for or
against that depending on whether they
thought it would make them or cost them
money short term so that's it all this
short termism that's going on i we think
is
is hurting people and undermining
business's role in society what what
types of market distortions
do you wish didn't exist or are you
trying to prevent all of all of them do
could you give are there are there any
particular examples that stand out for
you as sort of the the heavier Domino of
sorts or something that has particularly
negative cascading effects well I mean
the biggest are all these forms of
corporate welfare which I mentioned
occupational licensure the restrictions
on innovation and competition and
opportunities for those who start with
nothing as I as I said on occupational
licensure so this would goes with those
and then and then all the protectionist
provisions these trade restrictions this
are crazy immigration system all of
these are things we're working hard on
to to change it strikes me and I'm a
simpleton and pretty uninformed when it
comes to these things but that being a
privately held company allows you a
flexibility that some people in
leadership positions and publicly held
companies publicly traded companies
would feel they don't have which is a
benefit that that that you have for
instance if if you have because I would
imagine there are differing opinions at
at points so if you have an opportunity
or a say legislative or regulatory
change that could be short-term
beneficial profitable that is and that
they conflicts with with you Charles
your direction that you would like to
see things head on a broader scale for
human flourishing how do you have that
conversation among top brass in the
sense that revenue profit these
things that are easily quantifiable
whereas something like human flourishing
may be harder to quantify how do you
guys have a discussion when there's
there's disagreement we had those those
kind of disagreements decades ago but I
can't think of any of those now we may
have a debate on on whether it this will
help her her long term but it will it is
always will
will this enable to fulfill our
obligation as a business that is to
profit by helping others improve their
lives I mean what we do is we teach
these principles we have dozens of
people who work full-time on teaching
these and consulting on on these
principles of principles of human
flourishing and and how to apply them
that'll make us successful long term and
that's how we we try to reward our
people well first of all we hire first
on on values on our guiding principles
we have now eight guiding principles and
and so we hire on those we we reward on
those we promote on those and if
somebody isn't living by them we
encourage them to go somewhere else
because it's not a fit for them here and
so so we have harmony that doesn't mean
we don't have challenges and
disagreements but it's on how to do how
to realize this this vision and these
goals rather than whether we want to
sacrifice our principles for for
immediate gain so I would say what
guides us at first are are these basic
principles of human progress human
flourishing second is building
capabilities that will enable us to
create value for others and then do to
continually transform ourselves to do a
better and better job of that and to and
focus on using our
abilities to to contribute so that's
what's made us successful so I mean I
mean you look at our track record not
that we've been perfect and we haven't
had problems and haven't violated these
principles because we're all we're all
flawed we all make mistakes and and get
off track which we've we've done many
times and do it continually particularly
when it's we do have a hundred and
thirty thousand employees that's
incredible I mean it blows me away
constantly the power of these ideas
people say oh well you're so smart I am
NOT believe me everywhere I've ever
worked or whatever there are a lot of
people who are smarter than I am it's
just I was dedicated to understanding
and living by these principles and
that's what's made the difference in my
life that transformed my life well let's
I'd like to talk about your the
principles in your and your intellectual
formation and I set a book note to come
back to this and maybe maybe these are
the wrong trees to be barking up but
could you speak to I have a couple of
thinkers I've written down authors and
thinkers we've already talked about a
few of them Michael Polanyi we've talked
we've spoken about your father certainly
I have FA Harper author of why wages
rise ludwig von mises author of human
action among other things of course and
W Edwards Deming and wondering what what
are the main principles or lessons that
you've taken away from any any any of
those people we don't have to
necessarily cover all of them but if any
come to mind that we haven't given any
airtime to if there are any principles
or learnings that you you think are core
to what you took away from any of the
names that I mentioned right well we've
talked about popper and planean there
was another besides republic of science
that I got from Palani it's personal
knowledge that that in that too he's
read in a book but named personal
knowledge which
says there's a huge difference between
conceptual knowledge and personal
knowledge and he uses an example of a
concert violinist okay the first thing a
concert somebody wants to be a concert
violinist first how do I hold the violin
how do I move my hands how do I make
notes and and so they focus on the parts
and after these parts become natural
like the violin and becomes an extension
of your hands you don't have to think
about how to use your hands but that's
what he calls personal knowledge as
opposed to conceptual knowledge and then
after you do that enough where the parts
become second nature then you can focus
on the whole the whole is making
beautiful music and so that's what I
mean just that changed our whole
approach to teaching our management
philosophy because we were in its what I
called I think of a flaw in our
education system it's not really
education that schooling teach to test
and what we found in our programs that
works and helps helps people realize
their potential is to like is to
consider real education to be
three-dimensional rather than
one-dimensional and those three
dimensions are discover your gifts your
aptitudes and what will turn you on then
the second one is I do whatever you can
to fully develop those so first you
learn to be then you learn to learn and
then you learn to apply it okay how do I
apply these that will make a
contribution in society that will be
that will help me better myself and and
and in the process better others help
others better their lives and that's
three dimensional education and we find
that in the programs we've started
support that's what we're looking for
because that's that's what moves us
toward a society of mutual benefit where
where people have the opportunity to
realize their potential okay that's so
that's personal knowledge is another one
another one is the division of labor by
comparative advantage which also fits
Howard Gardner's thesis on multiple
intelligence that is basically that
people aren't smarter are dumb overall I
may accept in the in real extremes but
most of us are gifted in some ways and
and and not too Swift in others and that
I'm Exhibit A in that and so I mean that
was that division of labor by
comparative advantage I was first
developed by Ricardo on nations nations
ought to focus on what they're good at
and then trade with others and then I
that optimizes everything learning best
use of resources and so on another
concept is is creative destruction
Schumpeter's concept that is you don't
want to be protectionist in your own
shop that is you're doing something a
certain way like Kodak in in making film
rather than do it digitally they had the
technology but they've tried to protect
their existing product line and so ended
up growing broke so you've got to do you
want to drive creative destruction
internally that is constantly replaced
what you're doing with a better way a
better product a better technology
another one is self actualization when I
which I described and then another one
from also from Maslow and other positive
psychologists is what he called synergy
is a system and state of mind where what
selfish an unselfish merge I mean and
that's what he meant by
I mean contribution motivated that
focusing on helping others in a way
that's also rewarding to you then the
whole dichotomy between selfish and
unselfish disappears now that's an
idealized case that'll never be
perfectly true but if we could have a
society in an organization where that's
generally true then you're going to be
much better off and that's what we try
to apply here that is to have what's in
the long-term interests of the company
in the interests of the individual
employees and as I say learn that from
from Maslow and then and then free
speech and open inquiry is another one
the role of property rights and decision
rights which is a key one of the five
dimensions of market-based management
then basic values such as integrity
humility respect and desire to
contribute then another from this is
from von Mises human action model people
only act if the action will satisfy
three requirements the first is is you
become dissatisfied with your current
state you have a vision of a better
state and you have a path to get there
so this is very important for how
companies or societies organize
themselves if if people believe they're
dissatisfied with the current state they
see what's wrong with it but they have
no vision of a better state and because
you don't have free speech you don't
have communication they don't they
haven't seen a better alternative or
you're so bureaucratic and in
protectionist
you don't allow anybody to improve or
like in a company the approval process
is so painful and difficult
you just give up somebody we work with
in one of the major oil companies years
ago was always complaining about the
bureaucracy there and he couldn't do
anything wrong and I finally I said well
so what do you do about it and he says
well after a while you just paint your
ass white and run with the Antelope
[Music]
that's that's what what happens so these
these principles may seem obvious but if
they're are so obvious why are so many
countries organizations and people
ignoring them anyway
why why do you that's actually a
fantastic question why do you think they
are ignoring them because they're not
obvious or because there are other other
factors at play and then I want to segue
into after after you have a chance to
just comment on that to stand together
and and we'll provide some background to
that and then get into it but why do you
why do you think that these these
principles aren't are neglected is it
because they're not obvious because
they're difficult for for other reasons
I I think it doesn't fit their
priorities and I think a good part of it
is they're short term oriented rather
than long term oriented I think that's
critical and and as I say that's been
the demise of of so many companies
that's why you see companies the top
companies in the country 50 or 100 years
ago or all gone they're not all but the
great majority are gone or else very
declined markedly in their position yeah
yeah it's incredible how many blind
spots and maybe not incredible it's
totally sensible how many blind spots
are created by ignoring some of these
factors a friend of mine one of the
cofounders of a site and a service
called reddit who's been on the podcast
described a meeting with an executive at
at Yahoo at one point who dismissing Lee
looked at their numbers and said you're
a rounding error and of course that
didn't didn't work out
well for for Yahoo so the creative
destruction is really important well let
me let me mention one other principle
that's been critical in my life that I
touched on it and that is that as I said
I I have I just have a narrow range of
abilities developing those and focusing
on that and then partnering with with
people who could complement that and and
and what I've learned is to have a good
partnership that would do that requires
three things it requires shared vision
shared values and having complementary
capabilities and where I've had that
partners who fit those three or we fit
those three together then I've been very
successful where I haven't I've
generally failed and my best partnership
has been with my wife we've been
together 51 years and and we share
vision and values and I'm good at the
few things she is and she's good at
about everything I'm not good at so we
make each other better and so that's
been one of another one of my great
blessings and advantage in in my life
yeah I wanted to to ask you if perhaps
later well we'll come back to this but
what is factors that have made it work
the the the relationship with your wife
because we've we've spoken about that
before and I do want to come back to
that if we have the time to do so but I
also want to make sure that we have a
chance to cover and give you time to to
stand together as a way of getting there
because I think there are a lot of there
are a lot of passionate supporters and
there are a lot of passionate detractors
and at least in my own very small
microcosm of this my experience is that
the most intense supporters and
detractors
tend to miss things so I want you to to
correct me if I get anything wrong that
I'm gonna say as means of context but
just leading up to stand together
I want to paraphrase a former
Congressman Joe Scarborough this is from
that source basically the the gist of it
is although your critics are usually
unaware the the Koch brothers have
supported more than just Werner
generally considered conservative causes
they post george w bush and many issues
our pro-choice support same-sex marriage
and worked closely with the Obama White
House for the Obama administration's
criminal justice reform initiatives that
align with their own I've to two things
that I wanted to mention on criminal
justice reform and foreign policy and
then feel free to and I would love you
to correct anything that I get wrong
obviously but what's what's impressed me
about a number of the things that you've
done and probably many many things that
you've done is that you've allied with
former combatants as may be too strong
word but people with whom you've had
tension or people with whom you still
have many disagreements over different
things the first criminal justice reform
despite what I believe was pretty
adverse a relationship with activists in
CNN commentator Van Jones you ended up
collaborating to work together on
criminal justice form similarly on
foreign policy despite disagreements
with George Soros on many policy issues
you found the you had common ground when
it came to foreign policy so you were
able to partner with Georgia's open
society foundation the question I want
to ask you before we get to stand
together which we're going to in just a
few minutes is how is your approach to
policy did I get anything wrong I'm
cheating it's a two-part question and
then B how's your approach to policy
coalition's changed over time no that's
a that's a great question well I've been
at this social change and and
philanthropic approach for fifty five
years now and it was basically I had
learned these principles that
transform my life and enabled me to
[Music]
really realize my potential and
accomplish more than I ever dreamed
possible
and so I I had the desire to help as
many others have the same kind of
benefits in their own way to fit their
own situation and and gifts and so I
started as I say and I started in on
this in in 1963 and and for the first
let's say 40 years of that I wasn't
involved in politics at all I wanted to
stay away from that and and work with
helping people realize their potential
and supporting mainly students and then
as as the students talked to their
professors about what they were learning
working with with our organization that
the professor's would come and they want
us to help them set up a program to do
that so it just spread and then to get
things done we we decided we needed to
to build our organizations that would
well first of all that would take these
ideas and develop what are the policy
implications of these and so I helped
found the Cato Institute and a number of
other institutes to do that and then we
decided we needed to help mobilize
people more and more people were
interested in these ideas how do we how
do we get policy changes well we need to
mobilize people who were interested in
them and help them have a voice and so
we started doing that and then decided
we needed to get politicians more
politicians who would be interested in
ideas that would really help the country
long-term rather than just help them get
a reelected and so we started doing that
and the Republicans seem although far
from ideal seem more sympathetic to
these so we started supporting
Republicans and and then then we learned
that didn't get us anywhere so we have
changed no we're just we will go back
and support anybody who will advance
these policies that will help bring
about the Society of mutual benefit
where people have the opportunity to
realize their potential and so if you
put it in terms of my philosophy on
partnerships you share vision and values
and have complementary capabilities what
I was doing was applying to brought a
requirement for shared vision that is ok
wills only support those and work with
those who we share broadly a vision of
what kind of society we want it and so
that was really limiting the number of
people we could work with and so in the
last few years we've changed that all we
need is shared vision on a specific
issue and we may disagree on everything
else but if if you can really help us
advance this policy that will help
people improve their lives we will we'll
work together and so that's how Van
Jones has gone from being somebody who
was trying to shut us down to working
with us and bragging on us and and
enabled us to work with Soros and
everybody on specific issues other even
though we have major disagreements with
him and that see and then that fits
where we're finding is doing that it
reduces the the hostility and the
conflicts if rather you meet somebody
rather than try to find something you
disagree wheel on and fight them and
attack them search for something you can
work together
that will contribute that will help
people improve their lives and doing
that now we have allies I never would
have believed we can and now as this is
changed changing our brand and help
people look at us now many many more
people are open to working with us and
it seems like a lot of what you've done
not just in the last year's but
certainly even before that has led up to
this initiative stand together could you
tell us a little bit about that focus
and why it's a focus what it is right
we've we started the organization that
was originally stand together now stand
together foundation to build on the work
we were doing in troubled communities
and and our approach there is what we
call bottom-up as opposed to top-down
and it starts with the the recognition
as I've been saying that everybody has a
capability to realize their potential if
they have the right mindset and support
so how do we how do we help people get
the right mindset and support so they
can have a better make a better life for
themselves and it's as I say it's with a
bottom-up approach rather than a
top-down approach and what I mean by
that is rather than have somebody come
in and say well on average or we can
improve the statistics on this here's
what we're going to do and we want
everybody to do this same thing we find
that hasn't worked but what works is is
what we define what we call social
entrepreneurs who are closest to the
problem and this would be largely people
who who've had a problem have gotten in
trouble have been held back
[Music]
have learned to overcome it and now are
dedicating their lives to helping others
do the same so they have different
capabilities than we do we advertise if
you're interested in our help so you can
improve your efficiency by better
management practices and want to scale
and celebrate it so it can spread so
more and more people can benefit from
your proven approach then we'd love to
do that and so we've had several
thousand applications we now have a
hundred and fifty these partnerships in
these troubled communities on on
everything from addiction to to criminal
justice to homelessness from lack of
Economic Opportunity from two young
people who who have only seen a negative
contribution negative motivation rather
than contribution motivation and to help
them change their mindset that they can
succeed in contribute and you know it
strikes me and I'd love for you to
correct me if this isn't accurate but it
seems like you're taking a lot of your
experiences from say criminal justice
reform where you've focused among other
places on really analyzing recidivism
and reducing recidivism looking at how
to change things so that employment
opportunities for released convicts
aren't as constrained as they are
currently we're expanding those options
and I've actually spent time in some Mac
security prisons teaching
entrepreneurship with a number of
organizations that you're taking some of
those learnings and then applying it
more broadly to enable a community of
social entrepreneurs the so that some of
the numbers that I have in front of me
are in terms of the entrepreneurs and
groups who
focused on and it looks like there are
five five four key institutions
education business communities
government policy so you have a more
than a thousand professors at more than
350 universities tens of thousands of
k-12 teachers and this will lead up to a
question more than 700 of the top
business and philanthropic leaders that
combined employ more than more than 2
million people 140 plus community groups
tackling poverty and addiction I'm very
interested in addiction that's that's a
longer story for another time
but millions of grassroots activists in
all 50 states so this is is clearly
bottom-up like you mentioned I think a
lot of people when they when they hear
Charles Koch think market-based
solutions are market-based solutions
part of this we're looking for
market-based solutions or is it broader
than that well it's it's market-based
and in that it's it's looking at what
really works and looking at individuals
rather than I mean it market is a little
bit of a misnomer but it's applying the
same philosophy that that made Koch
Industries successful and enables us to
to help our our employees become
contribution and motivated and by the
way I you suggested this early and our
employees who after years of learning
they can succeed by constantly improving
their ability to create value for others
they tell me and and after they retire
or leave write me and say they they they
are so appreciative that they learn this
because it improved their family life
their communities their friendships
everything to look at it that way rather
than the way they were looking at it
before but so it's it draws yeah our
experience in criminal justice reform
but but more broadly our experience in
in what made Koch Industries success
what have made societies throughout
history success which ones have people
have flourished and which ones have
people have been admitted and what we
learned in in developing youth
entrepreneurs and that's an organization
my my wife and I started 28 years ago
here in Wichita as we saw met so many
kids that obviously had ability that
they did played sports with but we're
just getting terrible advice they were
came from broken homes and tough
neighborhoods where people were trying
to hurt each other so wow this is what a
waste so we need to start something
particularly in this in these inner-city
high schools that would teach them what
we call principle entrepreneurship that
is this to have create this three
dimensional education where they learn
they could change their mindset look in
spite of you thinking things are
hopeless from where you came from
they're not all you got to do is change
your mindset and then we'll provide the
support to help you become successful so
in youth entrepreneurs they theory what
are the skills and values they need to
be successful and discover their own and
then pair a business plan and the best
business plans will get some venture
capital to help you start your own
business and then will if you're
successful you can will will find a
local entrepreneur to help mentor you
maybe provide internships for you and if
you continue to do well you want to go
to trade school or college whatever fits
you will help you do that and it is
amazing the how many of these young
people's lives have been transformed by
this and and are running successful
businesses out of this everything from
car dealerships to the one developed a
protein bar that sold on Amazon
clothing lines chartering buses fitness
clubs Hair Braiding making jewelry
tutoring others I mean it is incredible
it just it blows you away when you send
these here these kids describe how
they've how this is transform their
lives so that's what motivates me not
just the theory but seeing what it
really does to change people's lives it
and with with something Charles when
you're when you're operating at such a
high level in many respects and you have
so many different places you could
allocate capital and effort what what
does success look like for standing
other foundations say a year from now
three years from now whenever you would
assess it to determine whether to put
more into that or more into something
else which could also be philanthropic
maybe just a new iteration or a new
foundation how do you how do you think
about what the success metrics are or if
not metrics what how you determine if it
is working or not well I mean what what
we're looking for these social
entrepreneurs is which ones can really
we help scale and then celebrate so it
could capture the the national
imagination and change the way people
think about these like criminal justice
reform I mean there it was what was
current and choice was okay somebody did
something illegal block them up and
throw the key away and and prison is for
punishment rather than to help them
rebuild and get a second chance now now
it's changing because we we and others
with Van Jones and others have built
these broad-based coalition's that
this first step Act passed by 87 votes
in the Senate I mean that's incredible
in this day and age to have this kind of
bipartisan support and there's impetus
to to take it to the next level but it's
it's changing life as people realize
that 90 some percent of people who go to
prison get out and do you want prisons
to be incubators for more hardened
criminals than they were when they went
in or you want them to have a second
chance and come out with a skill and
values that will enable them to
contribute and become contributors
rather than detriments to well-being and
safety and I mean for example one of the
groups we support Hudson link puts on
college accredited courses in prison
that that are three-dimensional as I
mentioned and and if the graduates of
their program has a recidivism rate
first percent that go back to prison in
three years after they get out it's 2%
from graduates of their program as
opposed to nearly 70 percent nationally
and 40 some percent in in New York where
they they have mainly operated and we've
helped them or they're up to five
prisons now and we think it can be
greatly expanded you've also done you've
supported some some really good work
being done in addiction treatment with
the Phoenix and I'll link to all of this
in the show notes so people can can take
a look at it
but it's it's it's really important work
these are important topics and part of
the reason Charles that I wanted to have
you on after you know months of just
organizing to make it happen is that in
very polarized times where you have
it could be any number of people the
President or someone else is the second
coming on one channel you flip to the
next channel and he or she is the
Antichrist that it is possible to attack
the issues or attack the problems and
not the people and while I'm sure that
and I would hope that if we were to
spend more time together you and I would
disagree on a lot of things that there
are things we could absolutely agree
upon and that provides the space to have
a conversation and discuss the
possibility of collaboration for things
that anyone can agree upon and this is
I'm really pleased to give some of those
specific examples because it's it's
paralyzing when everything becomes ad
hominem and so so that that's really
more of a comment than a question but I
just wanted to thank you for making the
space for us to to talk about that and I
do have some more questions but the
question about about the standing other
foundation are are you still accepting
applications by social entrepreneurs or
as has that window already closed oh no
we haven't actually helped change the
trajectory of the country more toward
this ideal so we're just getting started
we we're a world up to over a hundred
and fifty now of these social
entrepreneurs we're partnering with and
we think we're as we're developing
capability we can add as many as 70 a
year so we're just we like just
scratching the service and and then
developing the capability to help them
scale and then to to more fully
celebrate it to get this out in the
mainstream so people see what's working
and how how this approach
transform lives what what these
individuals have learned from their own
experiences and and are dedicated to
apply and those are my heroes in society
of people who have suffered injustice
tremendous injustice and rather than
come out better or giving up to dedicate
their lives so that others don't have to
suffer somewhere in justices I mean
those are that's if we can encourage
more more and more people to have that
frame of mind and that kind of
dedication that's the only thing I think
that will get us on a better trajectory
in this country people can learn more of
course I'll mention this at the end of
the show as well but stand together org
is a great URL and a simple URL for
people to remember for those who want to
learn more I'd like to shift gears in a
way but it's it's it's connecting a
handful of things and also giving us an
opportunity to talk about sort of ad
hominem vs. issue based debates and also
accurate perceptions versus
misperceptions so I have I have some
questions from my audience and there
were a lot of questions and I've
deliberately chosen a few that I think
tackle head-on or they don't really
tackle but I give sort of an emotional
voice to a number of things that people
some people rightly or wrongly want to
ask so the first one I'd like to throw
out and this is from Matthew B and you
can tackle this any way you'd like but
the gist of it is does he ever have
pangs of guilt about the millions of
Americans made poorer sicker or dead by
unfettered capitalism does he actually
prefer a world where the majority
struggle in misery so few can hoard
billions why are higher
margins worth polluting the environment
and how does he square that with the
animals and people sickened and killed
by deregulated industrial pollution so
that's very strongly worded of course
but I want to sort of give airtime to a
few of these questions and there are a
number of questions about environmental
issues and climate change so I'd love
for you to answer that in any way that
you'd that you'd like I mean I think
we've talked about you don't need to
answer do you prefer a world where the
majority struggle in misery so if you
can hoard billions I think that's a
pretty self-evident that your answer is
you do not prefer that but how would you
like to comment or respond to that you
know we we would agree I mean I'm not I
don't like the term capitalism that that
assumes that what we're after is a
system where certain people have a lot
of capital and that's not what we're
about what we're after is a system where
everybody has the opportunity to realize
their potential including those who
start with nothing and and business
should only profit to the extent they're
helping other people improve their lives
and that so and and polluting and making
people sick killing people is they
shouldn't profit they should bear a cost
for that and those are my worst you
talking you asked about failures our
biggest failures in my mind and what we
worked the hardest on are our safety
problems when there's an accident and
people die I mean that's monstrous so
that's that's job job one is keeping
people safe and job two is protecting
the environment and I think the last
five years the EPA has ranked us either
number one or number two of US companies
in pollution reduction initiatives that
is that is our second top priority after
keeping people safe so I mean we agree
to the extent but what you find is that
the the countries that do the worst and
those are those that are top down if
you're bottom up and you're looking at
individuals and how to improve their
lives it changes your approach rather
than some top-down statistical approach
or control and so that's been to me the
basic difference is do we want a system
that empowers people or one that
controls them and you look at systems
through history that have tried to to
advance humanity by controlling
everybody and making them follow some
theory of of the people in charge as
opposed to having incentives and rules
that will cause people to want to
believe that the way to succeed is by
helping others improve their lives I
mean the results throughout history
there is no comparison between the two
in in the benefit to human flourishing
I'm if you want to look at the biggest
polluters look at East Germany when when
that became combined with West Germany
they had all these inefficient factories
that were massive polluters and then and
then look at I don't know if you've seen
the documentary try Noble on the that
shows when things become politicized
they become corrupted and that's that's
why all those years I got had nothing to
do with politics and now we're we have
something to do with it but that based
on on not partisan but who's going to
help improve the policy so so we can
move toward this system of mutual
benefit
so I'm gonna ask just a few more of
these and I'm gonna alternate between
the the highly politically charged and
not so I'll go to one that I think is
not but I'd be curious to hear your
answer it was uploaded quite a bit this
is from John Jay asked Charles while we
can't return to the tax structure of
last century higher taxes equals higher
GDP we average twice the GDP of today
trickle-down never works
government is created or supported most
businesses in this country computers GPS
internet roads electricity etc what are
your thoughts Charles I mean I my
reading of history is is somewhat
different my I I don't I don't have a
dog in the fight because I'm not I don't
know well educated on this people are
liberated and empowered they succeed if
you look at the history of humanity for
all the millennia up until starting in
the 18th century there was barely ever
any improvement and because these were
top-down societies were those in charge
well they were they were beyond
authoritarian they were totalitarian and
people weren't allowed to think
differently if you if you violated the
religious dogma torture didn't tell you
either died or or changed your opinion
or were threatened with that and so
that's stifled progress and then
starting really in with Holland when
they got it from another Spanish rule
they started liberating so religious and
other dissidents started coming to
Holland and they had free trade open I
mean they had plenty of problems they
still had slavery which was endemic
everywhere but they had much more than
others so they became the most
prosperous country in the world and then
it it it followed in in England and then
spread to the United States these ideas
and was to me best embodied in the
Declaration of Independence that as a
system of equal right
and and everybody having the right to
the pursuit of happiness which to me is
a different way of saying the
opportunity to realize their potential
and who to learn contribute and succeed
and to the extent that was followed in
this country made us the us the most
successful country in the history of the
world unfortunately it was not applied
across the board for example African
Americans and Native Americans had no
rights obviously with slavery for
African Americans and practicing
genocide against Native Americans women
only had partial rights not just and I'm
not talking about just the right to vote
but they weren't allowed to go to
college in the early days they weren't
when they got married whatever property
they had their husbands controlled so
the relationship between husband and
wife was almost like a master-servant
relationship and it took 80 years to
remove the great majority of that then
very various immigrants such
particularly the Chinese and-and-and the
Irish had only partial rights and
certain religious groups didn't
so all these all those were violations
of the principles in the Declaration of
Independence and to me what we're
working on what stand together is
working on is to eliminate the the
aspects of all those in justices that
continue to haunt us haunt the country
today thank you a lot of I'm going to
jump back to the the more charged a lot
of these questions are about climate
change and I don't I don't know the
answer to this I'm just going to ask
since this is sort of a thematically
it's come up a couple
from Iman I'm not going to give a last
name this one is from Iman do you really
fund propaganda to confuse people about
global warming well I certainly hope not
believe me I am totally dedicated to the
scientific method in in good science and
what we're doing is is trying to get
various groups not people on the
extremes who say there there is no
man-made contribution to to warming or
others who say within a few years the
the world's going to end so leaving
those people out people who are somewhat
open-minded and willing to listen to the
other side to get them together and
we've had several of those sessions so
we can find something I mean there
there's enough concern about a man-made
contribution to to warming that various
policies are have been developed and are
being developed and so what we want them
to do is is to find policies that will
actually work actually do something
about reducing co2 emissions manmade co2
emissions and at the same time not make
people's lives worse many of these
policies haven't done anything reduce
co2 but they make people's lives worse
particularly the poorest and and the
biggest contribution or the biggest
reduction has been in the u.s. in recent
years because of fracking of natural gas
substituting for coal and so the u.s. is
now as figures I have seen is now
responsible for 15 percent of the co2
manmade co2 generation and a countries
in Asia particularly China and India
share is growing and the problem with
many of our policies as they
they are doing much for it and they make
us less competitive versus China and
China has double the co2 emissions per
unit of GDP that the u.s. does and so as
we push more over there push more
production over there we're just
increasing and uncertain of that of the
production there for example in
fertilizers and chemicals that are based
on coal gas rather than natural gas it's
four to five times the emissions per
unit of production so these are all
dilemmas that we try to do something
here
but it many of them make it worse so how
do we what we think we need are
innovations that are going to cause
China to adopt them and have them reduce
emissions rather than us try to do it in
ways that causes them to increase
emissions so that's that's what we're
working on and because it's not it's
just not once again it's just not a
simple top-down matter you've got to
provide incentives for people to to do
it and people have to believe it will
make their lives better rather than
worse and accomplish nothing which is
what a lot of the policies have done
yeah that's a great point about China
and offshoring that's I certainly hadn't
thought through as as granularly is that
I mean it's after if you're pushing off
production into a jurisdiction or just a
could be jurisdiction it could be
regulatory it could be cultural I have
no idea where the the the emissions or
pollution per unit of production is four
or five times higher you you haven't
solved the problem by changing the
location and you and you see that in the
world all these policies and all this
and these initiatives and co2 emissions
are still going up around the world so
we need a different approach I mean to
keep doing
the same thing over and over this is a
form of insanity so that's what we're
trying to do is get people focused on
something that will make it different
and not make people's lives worse
Charles this is a question for me just
building on that or related to it what
what do you think are the most
legitimate existential threats to
mankind if you go to Silicon Valley
artificial intelligence is a very
popular vote
you certainly have sort of climate
change or global warming depending on if
you're using whose wording you're using
which is the vote for a lot of folks in
your mind what are the if any the the
more legitimate existential threats to
humankind
I think the biggest threats as they were
for millennia
up until the 18th century are top down
the tyranny of experts the fatal conceit
that a few smart people can go tell
everybody how to live their lives and
what we're finding we're working with
these social entrepreneurs the ones who
have good solutions micro solutions not
macro solutions because they've lived
through problems and they worked their
way out of it and they know what works
and are proving it every day that that's
what we need
society as as Hayek found in history
that enables people to pursue their own
interests in a way that is mutually
beneficial and leads to peace and
harmony and these top-down solutions all
they do is create partisanship and and
and conflict and that's what we see
today in this country because it's
politics is win lose gain working
together to your mutual
benefit is win-win as opposed to win
lose so we need to maximize the amount
that we allow people to do to advance
their interests in a way that benefits
others are there any particular problems
that worry you or things on the horizon
that worry you that you think everyone
should be paying more attention to any
specifics that come to mind yeah I think
I think policies on trade and and
immigration it's what is attributed to
Basquiat
if Goods don't cross borders soldiers
will and to have and then our foreign
policy of forever wars that's why we
with with with cirrhosis foundation we
we created this the Quincy Institute
named after John Quincy Adams who said
following the founders we got we go not
abroad in search of monsters to destroy
we're the friends of all nations and
allies of none and so we're in dozens of
wars we have a over eight hundred bases
around the world we're involved in
everything trying to control the world
and it doesn't work this is totally this
is the most top-down of all yeah it
didn't didn't work very well for the
Roman Empire not to say they're
equivalent but quick review of history
it seems to indicate that that that
doesn't tend to pan out so well and then
you add nuclear weapons to the mix and
the more we we bully are like like we
did in Libya Gaddafi promised and got
rid of his nuclear ambitions and so we
destroyed him and so that creates a
little bit of perverse incentive for
Iran and North Korea and septa to
believe our promises that we'll leave
them alone
if if they'll drop their nuclear weapons
so I mean it's this stuff is so
backwards
what would this is this is a question
from I think it's joke amor hokum I
don't know how to pronounce it and I
know we probably have a handful of
minutes left if you're open to just
going for another maybe five to ten
minutes sure and his question is what
would you be willing to risk your whole
fortune for and and I'll just add my own
parameter to that which is it's not
necessarily betting the farm with the
company but your personal fortune is
there anything that you would risk a lot
of or your entire fortune for well I'm
investing all the liquidity I have in
stand together so I mean I The
Economist's have a concept called
demonstrated preference that pay
attention not to what people say but
what they do so that's what I'm doing
and that I dedicate a lot of my time to
that as well my time and right and
treasure and and so that's that's what
I'm I'm risking everything to and that's
that's the progress we're making there
is one of the reasons I get up in the
morning charged up every day yeah it's
important to have a reason to get up
which I think you're you're not to not
to hearken all the way back to this but
your chapter on incentives in good
profit actually touches on quite a lot
what would you put on a billboard
metaphorically speaking if you could get
a quote or a message question a word
anything non-commercial out to billions
of people is there anything that you
might put on that billboard yeah I put
night which is our our slogan that stand
together greater you're good and that's
because that's a little bizarre so that
what what are they talking about so you
would hope that then they'd follow up
what do they mean by that and yeah
what's he mean yeah and I mean just
exactly what I'm thinking I mean what
we've been talking about that is
discover your
your gifts develop them and apply them
in a way that helps others that's also
beneficial to you so you'll be motivated
to continue to do it well Charles it I I
don't want to take up too much your time
but I do have maybe a few more questions
and I want to we started close to the
beginning age six I want to say
something along those lines
digging dandelions let's go back even
further who were who were you named
after where do you get your first name
well my first and middle name was as
Charles de candolle and I was named
after an entrepreneur my father worked
for named charles de gallo and he he he
my father at age
I don't know 25 or so or maybe it was 27
designed a refinery for him on that I
love green and the UK and worked for him
for a couple years and they became
lifelong friends and he greatly admired
Charles de Gaulle's entrepreneurship his
integrity and his treatment of others so
that's who I was named after did did
Charles give your father opportunities
that were important early on or was
there did that factor into the the
friendship they developed or was it in a
broader sense what you just mentioned
yeah he his son Carl de ganar was a
classmate of my my father my father
started at Rice and studying chemistry
because the there wasn't a field called
Chemical Engineering and then after
during his sophomore year there MIT
started the first chemical engineering
department and so my junior year my
father transferred to MIT and and got
his degree there in chemical engineering
practice
and then he went to work for was Texaco
then and then the gasoline products
company which was a process design
company and in in all this he he
developed his own ideas on on refining
and upgrading heavy oil and so Charles
de Gaulle wanted to build this plant and
in the isle of grain and believe me
plants back then in the 20s were nothing
like today whole refinery would cost
maybe a couple of million and it was
primitive by today's standard but Karl
recommend to his father that he hired my
my father from from as an employee at
gasoline products company and so my
father quit guessing from went to work
for Charles de candolle so he gave him
that opportunity and and then my father
wanted to go in business for himself and
he he came back he came to Wichita
another classmate had an engineering
company and he joined there as a partner
he invested $300 and became a partner
and now the funny story is people wonder
well how'd you get the name coke how do
you pronounce that well my my my
grandfather my father's father
immigrated from the Netherlands in 1888
and and he didn't speak any English so
he came over he was the printers
apprentice and he went to work for
various Dutch newspapers and in that
learned to speak English and then he
heard about this print shop and and
weekly newspaper in quantity exis that
he and a partner could buy for I don't
know two three hundred dollars and so
they bought that and it was very poor
place they they mainly got paid with
blood farmer would have chickens or eggs
and deliver eggs or chicken or
or wheat or whatever is largely a barter
system because nobody had any money and
so that's where my father grew up and he
had this technical ability so he said
he'd he wanted to go somewhere where
there was more opportunity
so that's he went to rice and then MIT
and then ended up with his own business
and is is Koch the Dutch pronunciation
oh yeah thanks I got off the subject
yeah so so my grandfather pronounced it
call hard for English speakers well
particularly west accent said didn't
exactly fit their pronunciation so so
they pronounced it kaw
like a crow CAW Fred call that's the way
it's pronounced there my father hated
that pronunciation and one time he was
traveling on business and he was paged
as Fred Koch and he said I like that so
that's how we got her name so you can
see it has this elegant history from
royalties from the bartering with
chickens and having people address him
as coughing is so much that he took the
last name from an announcement that's
incredible
well Charles I suppose much like the
Charles that we mentioned who gave your
your father those opportunities early on
I'm really excited to see what stand
together does and what opportunities
they provide to people who could benefit
from them and hopefully like you said to
scale solutions that can you know
capture the imagination of the nation
that that's that's a that's a worthwhile
project and people can learn more about
that at stand together org they can
learn about all of the the company side
of things at Koch IND dot-com on Twitter
people can find stand together at at
stand underscore together and Koch
Industries is simply at Koch
industries is there anything else that
you would like to say or discuss yeah I
think there are a number of videos that
I've done and others have done on on
YouTube I think you can just go on
YouTube and look up Charles Koch and you
see mine and so you can but I mean I
mean particularly what I've said and
then you can you can judge me by that
I've done a number of of op-eds and and
I've done one with with Bloomberg on
free speech and open inquiry at college
campus Michael Bloomberg I've done one
with the Tim Cook on Apple on the
dreamers on making them permanent and
and we've we've brought dreamers back to
Washington and and to the Nasdaq to show
how many of them are productive bunch of
them work for us and other companies
Microsoft has joined us in that and then
I've done one with Michael Lomax the the
president of United Negro College Fund
on the work we've done with with that
organization to help students at these
historically black colleges to learn
principled entrepreneurship so that's
that's been another amazing story of
helping these students transform their
lives just like youth entrepreneurs has
been great I will I will get a number of
videos from your team and then we will
also link to the op-eds and for
everybody listening you'll be able to
find links to everything that we spoke
about certainly in the show notes at tim
dot blog forward slash podcast as always
and you can just search by the episode
or search coke koc ation it'll pop right
up
Charles thank you so much for taking the
time I know you're a very very busy man
you seem to be as busy as ever at 83
which I admire and I hope that this
episode will certainly bring attention
to stand together but even more than
that some of the the principles behind
it and the underlying ability if we
choose to exercise it to attack the
problems and not the people even with
the people you most disagree with on say
90 95 percent 99 percent of all issues
you can still find common ground so so
my hope is that this episode and the
stories that you've shared and certainly
the current initiatives also will show
people that that is a path you can
choose so thank you for making the time
Charles I really appreciate it well
thanks for having me Tim and and asking
some of the tough questions that's what
we need that's the scientific method
that challenge so I enjoy it and
appreciated my pleasure
thanks Charles yeah hey guys this is Tim
again just a few more things before you
take off number one this is five bullet
Friday do you want to get a short email
from me would you enjoy getting a short
email for me every Friday and that
provides a little morsel of fun for the
weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest
things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that I've
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ] that
I've somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
come that's four hour workweek calm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by ship
station
if you've ever sold anything online or
if you sell anything online then you
know what a pain in the ass the shipping
process is it's time-consuming it's
expensive
you're always copying and pasting orders
from different sites trying to figure
out the best carrier so on and so forth
it's such a hassle and in the previous
life I shipped tens of thousands of
units overseas domestically overnight
ground every possible carrier it drove
me bonkers ship station was created to
make your life easier I wish I had had
it when I was in the biz so to speak it
has the most five-star reviews of any
shipping software four point nine out of
five for Magento users four point eight
out of five for Shopify users four point
five out of five for big comics users it
goes on and on whether you're selling on
eBay Amazon Shopify or more than 100 of
the popular selling channels shipstation
lets you access all your orders from one
simple dashboard shipstation works with
all of the major shipping carriers
locally and globally including FedEx UPS
and the major local couriers like USPS
ship station will recommend the best
carrier for your needs so that you know
that you're always getting the best deal
they even offer discounts on shipping
costs that are available to say you as a
one-person shop that would normally be
thought of as reserved for large fortune
500 companies so there are a lot of
benefits no other shipping platform
makes shipping faster easier and more
affordable and right now Tim Ferriss
your listeners get to try shipstation
free for sixty days when you use promo
code Tim it's risk free you can start
your free trial without even entering
your credit card info just visit ship
station com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in Tim
T I am that ship station calm and
promo code Tim check it out shipstation
calm promo code Tim this episode is
brought to you by Express VPN
what is VPN virtual private network to
have that you run on your computer or
your mobile devices secures your
internet connection hides your public IP
address and lets you bypass regional
restrictions on content and I actually
asked my followers on Twitter 1.5 or 1.6
million of you for VPN recommendations
your favorites many wrote back that
expressvpn was their favorite including
a number of people who've been on this
podcast so I gave it a shot I've been
using it for a few weeks now and it is
ridiculously fast to the extent that I
thought I didn't have it on I could to
give you an idea expressvpn has
consistently rated the fastest VPN
service on the market it's incredibly
easy to use and it's one two three just
download the app tap one button and
you're connected to a secure VPN server
and I recommend checking out the website
just to see the signup flow they make it
really smooth very easy to sign up and
if you're an entrepreneur or do any
web-based front-end development or
design rather it's worth checking out
for that alone so expressvpn what we
talking about here
Swiss VPN is grateful and you need to
get work done while you're on some
sketchy Wi-Fi network for instance and
I've had a number of hacker friends of
mine show me how easy it is to sleep on
public Wi-Fi just right downloading
simple apps you do not need a computer
science background to do that which
scares the hell out of me so if you
don't want to be a victim of that you
can use Express VPN or if you're
travelling I need to access something
that's only available in another country
so let's say you're in a hotel in a
foreign land you light some candles and
you want to throw on some Pandora for
ambiance well
lickety-split expressvpn has you covered
Triss VPN is useful not only for
entrepreneurs and remote workers and
travelers like yours truly but really
for anyone who wants protection from
being snooped on or having their
personal data stolen so use it
constantly when I'm in airports coffee
shops and so on any public Wi-Fi
you just use the internet like you
normally would but with expressvpn
encrypting all of your network traffic
to safeguard your data so check it out
visit my special link at expressvpn comm
slash tim and you get an extra three
months of expressvpn protection for free
that's expressvpn dot-com slash tim and
claim your special deal visit expressvpn
comm slash tip
[Applause]
you